one of the most spectacular feats that a
work of fiction can achieve
is creating an utterly awe-inspiring
world
building a world that is not only so
interesting that it contains mystery and
intrigue at every corner surprising you
with every new stylistic flair but
also one that stays faithful to itself
establishing a consistent feeling of
immersion that never leaves until you
peel your eyes away from the media after
you're done watching
but most of all once that screen turns
to darkness
it's a world that still draws you in
even when you're not watching when you
aren't thinking about it the curiosities
of a stunning fictional world pull you
away from reality in a way that can't be
replicated anywhere else
and among the best pieces of fiction to
accomplish this daunting task of
mastering world building
in my opinion
is made in abyss
the manga for made in abyss already
feels
different
compared to the dark straight lines and
harsh shadows normalized in most manga
the art for made in abyss already sits
in an entirely different echelon
not necessarily better or worse as all
art is subjective
but more in tune with maiden abyss's
goal
to create a beautiful
flowing and natural world the shading
rounded lines it brings the images to
life
and sets a great foundation for the
anime to come which
through its clean animation and
attention to the living breathing
environment as well as its
groundbreaking soundtrack truly elevated
the world created in the pages of the
manga to one of the most immersive and
breathtaking atmospheres in all of anime
and today i'm going to break down
exactly how maiden abyss did that
[Music]
the story begins in the town of earth a
place that is quickly shown to have one
real reason for existing
to revere the abyss
on a lone island in the middle of a vast
unending ocean with thin streets and
precarious ledges along the town side
the story hones its sights onto the
singular spectacle in the center of it
all
to us nothing exists outside of this
island
even within the island the only item of
value that we see in these dilapidated
slums and less than average town
is its unwavering faith and reverence
for the abyss
in the orphanage where they are trained
starting from their early years to be
cave raiders in the abyss and where
massive celebrations are held in town in
remembrance of orth's bravest cave
raiders from the start of this story the
only sight we anticipate is what lies
below
and our main character rico is the
perfect person to take us there
rico is just a young girl who wants to
descend to the deepest depths of the pit
a tale that not a single soul has come
back and returned to tell
armed with nothing more than her
knowledge of many of the creatures and
sentient beings within the abyss and her
insatiable curiosity she acts as the
perfect vehicle for us as an audience
it is her childlike naivety and endless
desire to explore and descend further
that drives us to want the same and go
right alongside her
we are just as inexperienced and naked
in this new world of the abyss as she is
what lies below is an endless pool of
worlds to see places to be and
landscapes to run free
or at least that's what it seems like
[Music]
made in abyss just as quickly as it
establishes the hope of the abyss and
its natural draw
also makes the danger it poses all too
clear
with colossal monsters that will hunt
and kill humans without a moment's
hesitation and the curse of the abyss
which tears away at your body and
humanity should you attempt to even
ascend out of it
we are reminded of the beauty and the
horrors
of the abyss
rico's inability to fend off these
creatures and the universal and
unavoidable curse of the abyss show us
that these aren't mere obstacles between
the top of the abyss and the bottom
these can and will genuinely kill you
leaving you is nothing more than
ingredients for the abyss to further
feed itself
the act of entering the abyss holds an
unspoken agreement among every cave
raider
you will not
return to the surface
but every soul in earth shares the same
sentiment and bursting sense of ambition
it's the journey of a lifetime
i don't plan on returning
and then alongside rico and reg we enter
the abyss
and our lives are forever changed
afterwards
just like how my life completely changed
after getting nordvpn
have you ever wanted to watch an anime
support the creators by watching it
legally but can't find it on any
platforms
well that problem is completely
eliminated with nordvpn every country
has a totally different selection of
anime shows and movies and nordvpn
allows you to pick amongst thousands of
servers in over 50 countries and watch
everything that each country has to
choose from
i can't watch made in abyss here in the
us on netflix but after i jump over to
germany it's right here at my disposal
all of one piece in japan too i mean
come on
there's almost no show that won't be at
the tip of your fingers
it's an amazing way for you to expand
what you can watch while doing it
legally and while doing it safely you
can really make the most of the
streaming services at your disposal to
watch what every country has to offer on
top of this nordic bien has its own
anti-malware features meaning that when
you're reading manga or watching anime
online you will always be protected from
intrusive ads and web trackers that
nordvn will automatically block for you
by going to nordvpn.com forward slash
anime culture corner you can get my
limited time offer for a major discount
plus four months of nordvpn absolutely
free with any two-year plan
cyber security protection endless
catalogues of anime and shows and
high-speed international internet access
all within your grasp for just a couple
bucks a month
and even if you regret it after no
worries because you've got a 30-day
money-back guarantee but i don't think
you'll regret it
again that's nordvpn.com forward slash
anime culture corner the links in my bio
let's get back to the video
wow
i actually have my own vpn link that's
insane
one of the most incredible parts of made
in abyss's
well abyss
is its ability to emulate a full-fledged
world
in fact i'd say there are certain
factors at play that make it even more
interesting than what a typical
fictional world can be
the abyss contains layers each contain
their own set of unique environments
creatures and challenges
the second layer and its inverted forest
where even the water flows upwards in a
magical and unexplainable fashion
the fourth layer containing the goblet
of giant and the garden of eternal
fortunes
the curse of the abyss changes with each
layer as well
giving the characters another obstacle
to consider alongside the escalatingly
more life-threatening monsters
going from simple nausea at first to
pleading from every orifice to losing
your humanity in the point of no return
after the fifth layer
the further you descend into the abyss
you get more and more reminders that it
is impossible to return and that you
must keep going in the pursuit of the
bottom
the reason i think it's more interesting
than a lot of normal fictional worlds is
that there's never a sense of
complacency
you're always forced to push down and
even the slightest moment of retreat and
going back up punishes you
and everything abnormal that exists here
in the abyss is simply attributed to its
power
it is equated with god itself in the
story containing the power to manipulate
the earth and the people who inhabit it
but our characters also question whether
this is true
reg's backstory the power of relics and
white whistles why the curse of the
abyss exists in the first place
this pit is filled with just as many
mysteries as it has wonders
that is something that i believe is key
to an incredible fictional world
you continue to learn more and more
being surprised at every turn with
something new something else to
attribute to the growing lore of the
story
if i may i think a great comparison to
draw when talking about maiden abyss's
world and trying to explain it is
actually the world of one piece another
show that is revered for its world
building
[Music]
one piece contains a very similar layout
to made in abyss's world
upon entering the grand line it is a
straight line circumventing the planet
similar to the abyss lowering into the
earth
it also sets itself as a place of
complete wonder where no island is like
the one before it where you can sail
from an island coated in snowy peaks to
one covered in vast expanses of desert
dunes
it also offers a feeling of surprise
and the characters exploration of
islands floating in the sky and even
some sunken underwater with fish people
as well as countless mysteries as the
questions surrounding the void century
and the poneglyphs string our characters
along vast conspiracies
underlying the world of one piece
likewise new and powerful enemies hide
behind each corner posing danger to our
ambitious cast who must keep going
forward
these two shows are defined by their
feelings of wondrous unpredictability
all brought together to form a lone
single and straightforward journey
to the end of the grand line or to the
bottom of the abyss
without the overarching and defined
journey and destination the story would
surely get lost in its endless
environments and worlds and lose that
focus
in this way it stays grounded and tied
to a central idea
likewise the importance of the journey
and gravity of this situation would also
be undermined if there weren't genuine
threats to their lives to face along the
way
imagine if rico could just go back to
the top of the pit with no consequences
if these monsters weren't
life-threatening
would that be rewarding
most of all though aside from these
storytelling parts and the journey and
all of that jargon
at the end of the day the world of
maiden abyss is
simply
beautiful
when i first bore witness to maiden
abyss every new environment within the
show had me gawking
this is one of the few times where the
animation truly brings out the manga's
vision to an extent that really couldn't
be accomplished on the pages to a
colorful vibrant and emotive reality
smooth and flowy animation accompanied
by a real sense of scale and showing the
sheer size of the world rico and reg are
taking on as only young children
it makes for a stunning sight
and then after you're seeing all of that
your ears get blessed too made in abyss
rightfully has an incredibly extensive
soundtrack
after all you need that when you have so
many different kinds of environments and
settings to handle
the dark fear-inspiring lands to the
curious and bright forests
the soundtrack uniquely handles these
settings the moods they invoke
and it never gets old
it has songs you might only hear once
for a specific location
and then those that you might always
hear the ones that you will recognize
long after you finish the show that take
you on a nostalgic trip back into the
abyss
i didn't explain much in the way of the
story's plot because i wanted to avoid
spoilers
but most of all because
frankly
they weren't really all that relevant
after all the best part about an
immersive world is that it can bring
anyone into it with open arms
any person watching or reading
find themselves entranced
even though rico and reg are the perfect
characters to guide us through the abyss
their inexperience seeping into us and
really connecting us to their story we
could surely follow any character
and still be awed by the world
surrounding them
season 2 is airing now and it might be
the first time in a long time that i've
been very
very excited to see what was in store
make sure to check it out if you haven't
already it's amazing
don't forget to click on the link in my
description if you want to give nordvpn
a try on a two-year plan i do genuinely
recommend it i think it's got so many
uses regardless of what you want it for
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for a future in-depth show manga and
character analyses